let's talk about pumping ducks guys you
all know i'm a fan of the pump
always guess respect the pump but what
i'm not a fan of is
a pump and dump this is a technique that
has now become illegal in the stock
market but
right now because it's not regulated is
in this gray area with crypto and a lot
of people are promising
easy gains thousands of dollars doubling
your money
if only you join their pump and dump
group
all right guys welcome to the ultimate
crypto pumps today i'm excited to share
with you guys
that in this video you will learn how to
pump and dump
in finance huge profit i invested 8 000
and got
1600 back join our pump at them ultimate
cryptocurrency and you will
have the best experience ever so i
trying to figure out
how it works joined multiple of these
discord channels promising me
easy riches to figure out how this
scheme
sort of works now we're going to go to
the board we're going to talk about it
but let me say up front tldr these are
massive scams
designed to bring you in make you feel
like you're part of the group in reality
you're the sucker that's the whole game
is that
you if you are just joining one of these
groups thinking you're gonna make a
quick buck
you are the sucker and frankly i don't
know it's one of the few things that i
don't feel too bad for you if you fall
for this
if you're trying to get in on somebody
do a pump and dump and rip other people
off and you yourself get ripped off
that's not good okay i can't feel too
bad for you
but this is a big warning to all of you
who are seeing these
big pump signal groups big pump telegram
groups
they are fraudsters they're con men
they're liars tricking you out of your
money so if you have a friend
or anybody who's uh you know thinking
about getting involved in one of these
these are all the reasons you should not
be in the explanation of how the con
game works
let's go to the board shall we ladies
and gentlemen
welcome to the 10 million dollar studio
i'm your host coffee
zilla and today we're talking about you
guys know we're talking about uh
talking about the pump and dumps ladies
and gentlemen this is what it looks like
a lot of these are run on discord or
telegram um two of the more popular
you know messaging services with groups
so this is galactic
pumps is one of the ones that i joined i
also joined voyager pumps
big pumps signal you know things like
this and let me walk you through how
this works okay
so there's multiple days where they run
pump and dump these pump and dump
schemes right
uh so for example this is the 29th of
april
pump and dump dude they're shameless by
the way when law enforcement starts to
get ahold of this when regulation starts
to get ahold of you guys you guys better
run you better hope that you're
anonymous right but right now this is
all being done right out in the open
22nd of april pumping up they're doing a
pump and dump about
every three to five days and i quickly
found that the multiple groups that i
joined
a lot of them work together so for
example voyager pumps will work
with uh galactic pumps and they'll pump
the same
coins so what is going on as you can see
they use this
kucoin 29th of april and they pump the
same exact
coins now we're gonna go over the basics
before i explain exactly how this
fraud works because a lot of the people
in this group don't realize
that they are the suckers first of all a
pump and dump is where you artificially
raise the price of a stock or now a
cryptocurrency
artificially there's no reason it's
raised other than you're investing a
bunch of money
hoping that other people get in on it
and then you sell off to them
now typically this is done with like
kind of less known less popular
coins or stocks and this is because it's
easier to move the price of something
that is cheap right that is doesn't
require a lot of volume to move a lot
so they pick a bunch of like random you
know stocks or coins you've never heard
of before
so in the example of the 22nd of april
pump which i actually was witness to
here's how this works put up this bot
and they say it's a fair bot
how they pitch it to people is that
we're all receiving a random
coin from this bot and nobody knows what
it is before
it gets released now this is a lie but
we'll talk about in a second so they so
they give you this coin
so this is what that chart looks like
normally right you have a lot of
kind of random price movement when you
go to the time of the pump
this is what it looks like it is a very
clear
pump and dump here at one o'clock
is the pump and then every little
candlestick is another minute
and so it literally it's a pump and dump
for like five minutes right so the pump
happens in minute one and then it sells
off
very quickly now that you know what a
pump and dump is and what one looks like
though
um why is it a con why is this a scam
right
for someone to win in a pump and dump
someone also has to lose like
obviously right like if somebody's gonna
make money somebody on the other side
has to be losing money
and here's how they get you okay because
they try to tell the people in the group
that they're you're tricking people
outside the group they tell everybody
you know we're gonna post to social
media we're gonna fool them
see here's one such message from this
guy devin s
owens this guy's asking how many people
in this group or in this discord are
left holding the bag he goes in this
discord very very few it's the outsiders
that get shafted
bots that scan the market and people
waiting for trending coins see that's
the idea is like
if we all pump this coin together it'll
go trending on one of these crypto
exchanges
and idiots will buy in that's the idea
and then we'll
all the people in the group will make
money we're haha we're all in the know
we're scamming the world
and meanwhile it's the outsiders that
are getting tricked and they even
encourage people to go posting their
social media about the coin and whatever
and pump it
so that they can dump their shares or
their coins onto those people and make
money
now that is the lie though because the
truth about
these uh groups and all these things is
that the sucker
is not outsiders it's actually the
insiders
see here's how the scheme really works
so you take this
coin right that they pump and dumped on
april 22nd
they said that hey we're gonna get
social media we're gonna get
outsiders in on this coin we're gonna
get outsiders to buy what you're buying
right like to buy off of you
and then get they're the ones that are
gonna get dumped on but if you look at
how long the pump lasted it only lasted
a few minutes long
like five minutes in total not enough to
get a coin meaningfully
on trending so what's really going on is
that if you look back
at the volume history of this coin is
that you see something
very interesting you see a pattern of
by pressure over here slow buys
all the way up to the date of the
eventual pump
do you know who that is those are the
insiders ladies and gentlemen
that's right there's an insider within
an insider club
in all of these pump and dumps so
there's an inside group
who orchestrates this whole thing who
gathers people in who's who monitor it
who sends her comments
and they say hey guys we're going to all
pump and dump together but they know
beforehand what the coin is
so they spend weeks buying up that coin
slowly so
no one really notices and then the
second
that the buy the buy signal gets uh put
out
they put in a sell order and sell off to
you at those insane new prices
so the people who think they're insiders
are actually outsiders
and the only thing that is true about
outsiders holding the bag is that you
were the outsider all along i don't know
if any of that makes sense
but that's how these things work guys
and when you go to the comment section
of these things
people are going oh i lost money i lost
hundreds of dollars i lost
thousands of dollars and they can't
figure out why they thought they've done
something wrong and people will tell
them oh you were just too slow
but you weren't too slow you're just not
on the inside of the group
this group is conning you which is
ironic because you're trying to con
other people
and then you yourself are getting caught
there is a window if you're the fastest
clicker in the west though
no it's not about being a fast clicker
it's about literally knowing beforehand
what the coin's going to be but i think
what's most crazy about these groups is
just how widespread and popular they are
despite being such
kind of obvious scams once you've gotten
burned once i don't know how many people
are aware of this
they have 450 000 members just in this
one group or sorry 171 000 and this one
group telegram group
but across all their little platforms or
different discord groups they have 450
000
almost half a million people
participating in these strange
pump and dumps which are so obviously
built to just
benefit like a few people in the know
and there are a bunch of reddit threads
on this
um about pump and dump schemes but i
just thought i'd make my own video
because i think they can be really
dangerous these big pump signals any any
kind of pump and dump
scam they always say that they have
outsiders but
actually you are the outsider and that's
just what i wanted to come on here and
say
please don't get involved in these
ridiculous schemes they're built
to prey on your sense of like fomo your
sense of wanting to get in on this big
those big gains
but the reality is you can't it doesn't
matter how fast your fingers are
it's about knowing beforehand what's
going on and if you think you're going
to be a winner here
that's them preying on your psychology i
mean literally you have to know you have
to be in the inside circle to win
and at that point you're just lying to
people to make money again
i never knew that these pump and dump
groups existed
until i joined them i didn't know how
many people they had involved
and it's disgusting to me that nobody's
regulated these things yet but i think
they will be regulated soon
and you better be careful because if
you're caught holding the bag it's gonna
be a bad time
all right that's basically it see ya
wake up and smell the coffee